je pense que ça c'est le défi numéro un
de bon nombre de parents gérer les
écrans dans la vie de leur enfant et
cette semaine une étude qui a attiré
notre attention qui observé des
changements sur le cerveau des enfants
qui regardent trop d'écran renoma
nogueira ganic est avec moi ce matin
bonjour bonjour bon c'est pas la
première étude qui se penche là-dessus
mais qu'est ce qu'elle a de spécial
celle ci il ya beaucoup d'études sur le
sujet parce qu'on craint qu'un début et
des conséquences sur le développement du
cerveau des jeunes enfants il ya des
études qui ont déjà suggéré par le passé
que l'utilisation de téléphones
cellulaires ou de tablettes ça pouvait
avoir des effets négatifs par exemple
sur les performances scolaires des
enfants
peut-être même sur le taux de suicide
mais aussi d'autres études qui ont
montré que ce genre de liens là
pouvaient pas été pas aussi claire on ne
peut pas le faire tout de suite comme ça
et même si ça fait longtemps que les
écrans de télé ou les écrans
d'ordinateurs sont dans nos vies ça fait
uniquement une décennie qu'on fait face
à des appareils dont l'objectif
principal est vraiment de capter de
maintenir notre attention le plus
longtemps possible
donc pour mieux comprendre en 2015 you
l'institut national de santé américain
qui a lancé le projet abcd pour
adolescentes brink of native development
et don qui est son projet qui regroupe
21 centres de recherche qu'un budget de
300 millions de dollars et les
chercheurs vont suivre onze mille
enfants pendant une décennie pour
vraiment essayer de comprendre de voir
quel effet l'utilisation de ces écrans
le peuvent à bord sur leur développement
ils sont en a beaucoup parlé cette
semaine parce que leurs premiers
résultats ont fait l'objet d'un
reportage à l'émission d'affaires
publiques américaines six teams et nette
s'était repris après dans beaucoup de
médias ici et en europe
et qu'est ce que les chercheurs ont
observé exactement mais ce qui les
intéresse beaucoup c'est vraiment de
voir l'effet des écrans sur le
développement du cerveau parce que entre
notre naissance jusqu'à l'âge de un peu
plus de 20 d'un peu plus de 20 environ
il se passe énormément de choses dans
notre tête en 0 et 2 1 et des millions
de nouveaux neurones une nouvelle
connexion qui se font à chaque jour mais
en même temps il y en a des millions
d'autres qui se défont et cse rebrassage
perpétuelle de nos neurones qui vont
compter qu'il va continuer jusqu'à la
dollée jusqu'à la fin de l'adolescence
pour vraiment lancer le développement
notre cerveau surtout pendant le
développement de la région qui s'appelle
le cortex préfrontal ceci la région
qui est responsable de votre
raisonnement structuré et aussi de
contrôler nos impulsions et donc les
cherche l'objectif des chercheurs c'est
vraiment de voir si un niveau seuil
d'utilisation d'écran qui va entraîner
des conséquences sur ce développement la
du cerveau et qu'elles vont être ses
conséquences
est ce qu'il ya des premiers résultats
qui sont sortis oui c'est en suivant
4500 enfants ce que les chercheurs ont
remarqué c'est que ceux qui avaient
l'utilisation d'écrans plus abusive et
l'on parle d'environ sept heures par
jour toutes catégories des francos
d'écran confondues
c'est ça la tablette le téléphone la
télé un peu tout ça c'est ta par jour
minimum sept heures par jour minimum ces
enfants-là avait un amincissement au
niveau de leur cote de la région du
cerveau qui s'appelle le cortex cérébral
sociaux la région qui responsable
d'analyser toute l'information
c'est un résultat qui surprend beaucoup
mais faut rappeler que si faut spécifier
que cet investissement là ça fait parti
d'un développement normal du cerveau
c'est un phénomène par lequel le cerveau
va sélectionner les connexions qui sont
les plus utilisées et éliminer celles
qui servent pas à grand chose donc c'est
normal mais là ça arrive de façon
prématurée dans leur cas c'est
exactement ça c'est quelque chose qui
arrive à tout le monde mais qui arrive
plus tôt dépendamment de l'enfant on
parle quand même d'années mais qui
arrive plus tôt chez les enfants qui
utilisent ces écrans l'autre façon
abusive donc à l'heure actuelle les
chercheurs ne peuvent pas dire si c'est
vraiment les écrans qui sont
responsables de cet effet là ils savent
pas non plus 6 a des effets positifs ou
négatifs dont ils vont pour cela il faut
qu'ils continuent
c'est une première cette étude est une
première image si on peut dire ils vont
continuer de les suivre pendant la
décennie qui vient
mais le fait qu'il ya une différence dès
la première observation ça montre que
quelque chose quelque chose d'important
vient de se passer ici et à quel moment
ce qu'on va pouvoir tirer les
conclusions c'est dans dix ans où il ya
différentes étapes pendant pendant
c'était le coeur des résultats c'est sûr
qu'il faut attendre la fin de la fin de
l'étude dans une dizaine d'années pour
vraiment voir qu'est ce qui se passe
dans son ensemble pour être sûr de pas
tirer des conclusions hâtives mais on
s'attend quand même à ce qui est des
résultats qui sort tout fait au fur et à
mesure on va peut-être on va avoir des
nouveaux résultats en 2019
mais dans tous les cas ça va être des
résultats ce n'est pas là la raison pour
laquelle c'est important d'attendre
c'est que c'est des résultats qui vont
très difficile à analyser ça peut être
influencé le développement du cerveau
par beaucoup de choses
par exemple on sait que l'utilisation
abusive de tablettes ça peut avoir des
conséquences négatives sur
la qualité et la quantité de notre
sommeil et vu que les adolescents ont
besoin de 9 à 10 heures de sommeil par
jour dans leur développement normal mais
une diminution des horloges ça peut être
ça qui vont courir à entraîner les
conséquences négatives qu'on a vu dans
cette première image on sait pas non
plus si l'abus des écrins c'est quelque
chose qui est entraînée par les écrans
eux mêmes ou si c'est des problèmes qui
existaient déjà dans la vie des
adolescents mais que ces écrans la lui
serve surtout d'échappatoire donc c'est
une question qui est très complexe dans
son ensemble et en attendant d'en savoir
plus pour ça que beaucoup de médecins de
médecins pédiatres qui suggère aux
parents d'éviter les écrans totalement
pour les enfants de moins de 24 mois et
de limiter à moins deux heures par jour
pour les enfants plus âgés de modérer à
moins de deux ans par jouer moins deux
heures par jour pour les enfants plus
âgés qui vraiment rien pour les moins de
24 mois
donc tout ça de façon préventive en
attendant d'avoir ces résultats là parce
que ces dix ans plus tard exactement
excellent merci aux coûts renault ça
fait plaisir ici au vent
[Musique]